Gaeta Matarazzo seemingly came out of
nowhere - well Netflix subscribers has
Justin Henderson and stranger things but
there's more - Matarazzo than just D&D
endemic organs what matter Rizzo is
still quite young there's plenty you may
not know about the young curly headed
celebrity before he was warming hearts
as Dustin Matarazzo was belting out
ballads on Broadway at the tender age of
8 he played Benji in the 2011 run of
Priscilla Queen of the desert based on a
1994 film from the glitz and glam of
Priscilla matarazzo went on to the role
of Gabbar Raj in the 2014 one of late
miserable Matarazzo is never far from
his Broadway roots continuing to sing on
various television shows and regularly
going to see stage performances he's
also set to play Jack in an upcoming
Hollywood Bowl production of into the
woods Stephen Sondheim subversive take
on classic fairy tales many actors who
starts out on stage end up leaving it
behind for television and film but it
seems that Matarazzo was content to
continue performing on stage and screen
it's really cool to like have a job is
something that I love the young actor
cites his older sister Sabrina Matarazzo
as part of his inspiration to pursue a
career in performance Sabrina started
out in community theater and the since
her roles in a couple of short films as
well as one episode of the Americans but
she's not the only talented matarazzo
sibling in 2015 Matarazzo congratulated
his younger brother Carmen on his first
show a community theater production of
into the woods Junior it seems that all
the matter as our kids have a deep
affinity for acting and it's likely
we'll be seeing more Sabrina and Carmen
in the future in 2015 a year before
stranger things made him a household
name Matarazzo had a one-off role on
NBC's crime drama the blacklist the
episode titled the Kenyon family number
71
features a polygamous co-leader
harboring some dangerous goods Matarazzo
plays a kid named Finn who's been
brainwashed into carrying out a bombing
attack one stranger things ends
Matarazzo will have his pick of roles it
will be interesting to see if he sticks
with dramatic fare like the blacklist or
branches out in the different genres
even within the confines of stranger
things he showed an aptitude for comedy
drama and horror born in Little Egg
Harbor Township New Jersey Matarazzo was
only a couple hours away from the bright
lights of Broadway despite his rapid
rise to fame and his ever-increasing
paycheck from Netflix currently at two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
episode for stranger things season three
matarazzo was not relocated to Hollywood
his life after stranger things said
seems to be fairly typical of any
American sixteen year old he goes to
school and in 2019 he even went to prom
with his girlfriend Lizzie you
it must be daunting as a young person to
have his entire life on display for
millions of people to say but Matarazzo
seems to be taking it in stride living
his life as normally as he can given the
circumstances
the curly-headed actor is the lead
singer for a rock band called
work-in-progress a seven person ensemble
which includes both of his siblings
along with a few friends half the band
is me and my brother my sister that's
three of us right there and then the
other three are they all went to our
school the group has very diverse taste
in music covering songs from bands
including Led Zeppelin and the Black
Keys speaking with the Aquarian matter
Raza was said that his two favorite
bands to cover a po jam and Green Day as
he's a big fan of both Eddie Vedder and
Billie Joe Armstrong
according to Matarazzo his dad
introduced him to Pearl Jam's music and
he's seen the grunge band play multiple
times work-in-progress is recording his
own original songs now with catchy
titles like Dream Eater which kind of
sounds like something that might come
crawling out of the upside down as many
dedicated fans no matter aza was born
with a genetic condition called Clyde Oh
cranial dysplasia or CCD
this condition affects the development
of bones and teeth and though Matarazzo
seems to have milder symptoms and many
others with the disorder he was born
without collar bones and is missing his
front teeth he's undergone several
surgeries to mitigate his symptoms had
two surgeries that have had four
extractions and I have more teeth than
most people that I feel like okay I bet
you're Keith but this C CD does not seem
to be preventing him from living a full
and exciting life though it did prevent
him from getting acting work early on so
this sends Matarazzo was chosen to raise
awareness of this rare disorder among
his fanbase but he works to raise funds
to help those diagnosed who might not
have access to the full breadth of
treatment he is working closely with the
group CCD smiles at a spokesperson and
collaborates on Dustin themed
merchandise to raise funds for those in
need
mutter as o--'s Twitter and Instagram
feeds are a constant string of causes he
hopes to bring to his fans attention
most recently he teamed up with Verizon
to help raise funds for first responders
through the Gary Sinise foundation
Matarazzo also supports a non-profit
restaurant called Soul Kitchen
who
donated proceeds go toward helping
individuals struggling with food
insecurity perhaps suffering a genetic
disorder has given him a certain amount
of perspective about struggling with
uncontrollable circumstances or perhaps
it's just in his nature to pay his good
fortune forward Matarazzo appeared in a
few music videos back in 2017 the most
well-known of these would probably be
Katy Perry's swish-swish featuring Nicki
Minaj in the video Matarazzo plays
Perry's teammates on a basketball team
with a reputation for being big-time
losers matarazzo 'he's nickname in the
video is tragic Johnson and he's one
among a lineup of lousy ballplayers in
computer games his lost boy's life video
Matarazzo plays a role of an adult who
is to quote the lyrics living a lost
boy's life in the video Matarazzo wakes
up goes to his terrible job argues with
his boss and gets fired but when
everything seems bleak he picks up a
guitar and starts leading a more
personally fulfilling life through music
Muhtar also made headlines when his
Netflix reality show prank encounters
was announced the show which matarazzo
was both hosting and producing is set to
air sometime in 2019 the premise of the
show is that people show up for their
first day of work to find themselves
besieged with weird pranks critics were
concerned that vulnerable jobseekers
were being fooled into taking fake jobs
and wasting precious time and they could
be seeking out real employment tricking
the desperate doesn't seem like matter
as usual way of doing things and both he
and Netflix work to clear up the
misunderstanding participated fully
aware that was going to be a one-date
gig going in and everybody was
compensated Matarazzo was set to star as
Rami a young camel crossing the desert
in search of his human friend in the
20/20 film hum there's not a ton of
information about this movie as of right
now but he'll be working alongside Simon
Pegg who's playing the villain and Rami
Youssef who plays a human friend Omar
Robert Gibbs an animator on Fern Gully
the last rainforest Toy Story 2 and
inside out is directing Once Upon a Time
Matarazzo slist prevented him from
getting any roles at all and now he'll
be acting with only as voice as a main
character of an animated film check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos but your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]